in Britain has condemned Russia after a
Critic of President Putin who holds dual
Russian British nationality was jailed
for 25 years the foreign office has
summoned Russia ambassador to the UK
over the matter Vladimir Kara Mirza was
convicted on charges of treason and
spreading false information about the
Russian military in Ukraine well in a
statement this morning the Forum
secretary James cleverly said Vladimir
kazemova bravely denounced Russia's
invasion of Ukraine for what it was a
blatant violation of international law
and the UN Charter Russia's lack of
commitment to protecting fundamental
human rights including freedom of
expression is alarming we continue to
urge Russia to adhere to its
International obligations including
Vladimir Kaza mersa's entitlement to
proper Health Care the so who is
Vladimir karamoza well he's a 41 year
old historian journalist and opposition
politician who's criticized Russian
President Vladimir Putin and the
invasion of Ukraine
he holds Russian and British passports
having studied history at Cambridge
University
and he was a close associate of Russian
opposition figure Boris nemzov who was
assassinated near the Kremlin in 2015.
well twice in 2015 and 2017 he fell
seriously ill in what he alleges were
poisonings by the Russian Security
Services well following this story for
us our International correspondent John
Sparks who joins us now from The
Newsroom and John what is the wider
picture why do you think obviously aside
from the fact that he's an opposition of
of the government has Russia taken this
action
well I think there has been a a collapse
in this space which allows people to
express their their views freely and
essentially that is what Kara maraza did
he criticized the invasion of Ukraine
and he has been a long-term opponent of
President Putin but I think the dynamic
changed post the invasion in February
2022 new censorship laws were brought in
by the Russian government tolerance for
Dissent has basically collapsed in
Russia Russia and what caramoza did very
interestingly was he continued to speak
out when many liberal-minded Russians
were leaving the country when they were
trying to get out caramoza was going in
he had been recuperating in the United
States along with his family for some
time after the second of two poisoning
attempts attempts to to kill him he
blamed the Russian Security Services is
a a well-known Democrat in that country
although he and his associates in the
people's freedom party his other his
other colleagues pro-democrats in that
country have really struggled to make
any inroads but he was a voice of
opposition he suffered from two attempts
two poisoning attempts to attempts to
kill him in 2017 he went to the United
States with his family to recuperate he
came back he continued to criticize the
regime and what the Russian government
what President Putin ultimately have
done is that they have shut him down
they have shut him up for 25 years that
is
well it's unprecedented in its harshness
essentially for for criticizing the
regime for criticizing the invasion of
Ukraine it certainly sends a message to
anybody else in Russia similarly minded
to speak their mind